I am maybe Superman with some kind of
beacon for them to creep back from the
shadows oh I'm not gonna kill ya I'm
just gonna hurt you
really really okay yes you've seen some
terrible stuff come out about this movie
but that trailer was not a bad trailer
it was actually pretty good at the San
Diego Comic Con Suicide Squad released a
new trailer where we finally got to see
some of these colorful weirdos in action
what can we tell from this trailer and
how does it tie into the DC Cinematic
Universe more than you might think
I'm Gabe Hill writer let's see if this
trailer will reveal if Suicide Squad
will suck or not this is hashtag news
what is the Suicide Squad let me catch
you up real fast The Suicide Squad is a
group of criminals they're bad guys
exactly
captured by the US government and sent
on suicide missions to earn their
freedom their boss Amanda Waller
surgically implant slums in their neck
to force them to do her bidding so you
probably better do what she says
I'll blow your head no here's what I
liked about it at the center of the pre
trailer squad traversée is the Joker
honestly I thought he looked kind of
dumb with all the release pictures and
leaked footage the tattoos everywhere
the damaged written across his forehead
and put seeing him in action kind of
change my mind his presence is kind of
scary mostly because he's not trying to
overdo it
I'm just glad they're not trying to
replicate Heath Ledger's Joker oh the
voices sound kind of the same oh yeah
why so serious the trailer overall is
pretty Harley Quinn focused I'm excited
to see this girl on screen she looks to
be the right amount of creepy and
intense with all of our gymnastics and
hair colors and if you look closely we
get to see some apart Lee Quinn's origin
story as Harleen Quinzel The Joker
psychiatrist who he drove Matt and in
the shot at the end of the trailer it
looks like he might be giving her
electroshock therapy Oh
Viola Davis says Amanda Waller seems
like a hard-ass stone-cold B word but I
still would have cast over
excited to see Cara Delevingne a as
enchantress and the rumor is that she
might be hunted by Lex Luthor to be used
as a bioweapon interesting to see DC
tying its other villains into this movie
now here are some things I'm not so
excited about Will Smith as Deadshot is
still kind of just being real smithy
with some kind of Suicide Squad so save
the world
welcome to Suicide Squad maybe your
surprises though I am excited to see the
Joker but remember he is not a part of
the Suicide Squad so there's a chance
he's not really gonna be a huge part of
the movie but you can't tell Harley
Quinn story without the Joker being
involved her story's very much tied to
his she's obsessed with him so maybe
it'll be like a Hannibal like connection
with him being her evil inspiration or
maybe not Killer Croc seems to have the
Hannibal Lecter impression on lock so
I'm excited to see the DC is trying to
expand its Cinematic Universe here but
there haven't been a whole lot of origin
stories for DC characters so they're
really jumping right into the middle of
things that might require a bigger
suspension of disbelief so know that
going into it
DC's attempt to catch up and compete
with Marvel's seem to be skipping origin
stories that span entire movies and
instead covering hero and villain
origins in quick flashbacks note
enchantresses origin quickly teased in
the trailer and even Batman's in the
Batman for Superman trailer characters
like Killer Croc might be a little bit
harder to swallow if you don't know the
origin story it's still an uphill battle
for DC to catch up to Marvel it's a big
risk but it could pay off big-time
lastly the Joker's tattoos we could lose
a lot of them I'm just saying although
the mouth thing is pretty rad I do like
that everything else could be massaged
so what's just a movie by this new
intriguing badass trailer and not these
set photos that were released months ago
make your own decisions don't just
listen to me but listen to me because I
know what I'm talking about the trailers
good you should like it so now's your
chance to respond drop a comment in the
comment section I'm gonna be in the
comments I'll be like literally chilling
there so try not to like hit me with
your comments but tell me what you think
this movie's gonna suck just move you
gonna be radical this is the place to
figure it out let's talk about it oh we
got one more thing could you just do me
a favor subscribe could you because we
get to talk about all our our Superman
and our Batman and Wonder women but not
if you don't subscribe if you don't
subscribe it all ends
it all falls apart I've been Gabe hole
writer and I'm going to get some tattoos
removed
see you later guys you ready right that
looks like it